this is like old-school glamour I love
this look what inspired her um it's
cushiony the classic could chic and here
for JLo so I figured that was the way to
go well this is the thing so we saw
Jennifer Lopez like I think two weeks
ago and she was saying that she lost her
mind when she met you on set and like
she's the biggest Jennifer or Vanessa
Hudgens fan is that we have the bite
like I wish I had it on my head right
now what does that mean to you like your
Idol is obsessed with you like yes she
is definitely an idol of mine and I look
up to her so much but beyond that like
she's become such a good friend an
amazing supporter and I just love her as
a person so much did you get to do any
scenes with Milo I didn't know separate
parts of the movie a completely separate
because we also must together and he's
like the sweetest person yeah we love
him he's so sweet I told my boyfriend I
was like you guys have your really good
friends did you're both gentlemen which
isn't really like a thing that's around
much this is these days
where's your man tonight he doesn't want
it like the I at what
no no he's not here he went to a dance
but you know there's things that need to
be done okay but just looking your woman
right now you know yeah but at the end
of the my husband's are here either tell
me about the new music so many things
are going on with you right now I love
this it's like a very busy 2018 yes it
is well I mean life's short so you've
gotta do as much as you can
the song I did with phantoms called lay
with me I'm really proud of it I love
the music video they had this idea of
like throwing it back to our roots and I
was like what if we just did like a
breaking free moment and give the fans a
little nostalgia like yeah yeah sure
more music record what's happening
oh no and that's not the main focus
right now but I'm sure it'll come back
interview are such good friends with
Jennifer Lopez can you give us some like
secret nods of what's gonna happen
tonight during her performance I
actually have no idea I know this song
and the song is amazing it's so good I
mean it was written by SIA it's just
like it's such a great song like it's a
little emotional tonight okay is I mean
like it's a really powerful song she's
basically conveying to the message that
you are limitless like to all women out
there like and it goes to the movie so
well cuz the main thing is like the only
person holding you back it's you so it's
a great message the other thing that I'm
very excited about is the return of the
rom-com because the thing is is that
it's been like superhero movies and then
Indies for like many many years and I
love that jennifer is like pushing this
through you're a part of it
like sometimes a girl just wants to sit
and watch a romantic comedy God more
like all the time fulfill our rom-com
dreams oh yeah and then some it's gonna
make you laugh it's gonna make you cry
it's gonna make you feel good and it's
coming out of my birthday which I'm
really excited
go to the like launch party or do you
throw a birthday party both your
birthday party thrown by JLo I love s
like thanks Jen the best thirtieth
birthday present can I see the purse
just before you as you walk away because
that is so cute
[Music]